Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
‐Let's go, baby!
‐Whoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
Do not judge me by my sales.
‐Oh!
‐Yeah!
Daymond would have been
a great partner,
but he threw me
under the bus.
Absolutely not.
Uh‐oh.
♪♪
You suck!
You gave me
Carolina blue?
You're a great guy with
a really, really bad idea.
Well, Sharks,
I brought backup.
That's brilliant.
‐Don't overthink the putt.
‐[ Laughs ]
Mah!
[ Gasps ]
♪♪
Ohhhhhhh!     Ohhhhhhh!
Ohhhhhhh!              Ohhhhhhh!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is a new concept in footwear.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Ryan.
This is my brother Eric
and my best friend, Kev.
And we're
the MUVEZ team.
And we're seeking
a $200,000 investment
for a 15% equity stake
in our company.
Sharks,
I don't know about you,
but when guests enter my home
and keep their shoes on,
it drives me crazy.
Oh, yeah. He gets really,
really incensed about it.
"Shoes, bro!"
You're tracking in
dirt, bacteria, and
who else knows what?
He's right, so for Eric,
we make sure
we wear our slippers
around the house.
They're great and all,
but if I have to run
outside for a quick trip,
like taking out the trash
or walking the dog,
I'm gonna have
to find my shoes,
put on socks, tie laces.
I just want to go.
If it was up to me,
I would leave the house
and then come right back.
Shoes, bro!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So to fix this common problem,
we created
MUVEZ Footwear.
MUVEZ Footwear is the only
footwear on the market
with dual‐sole
technology.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Nice.
So now Eric can keep
his floors clean
and Ryan can transition
to an outdoor shoe
in one easy step.
While he's out and about
in his MUVEZ,
he's both comfortable
and stylish.
No one even knows
he's in his house slippers.
We engineered the MUVEZ
to hold on tight,
whether he's walking, running,
or even jumping.
‐Whoo!
‐There it is. There it is.
Give it to him.
Eric: The coolest thing about
having removable outsoles
is they're all completely
interchangeable.
Now changing
the look and feel of your shoe
has never been easier.
Zamora: So, Sharks, who's ready
to join the movement
and help the world
move easy?
‐Wow.
‐Can we try the MUVEZ?
Of course.
Thank you, guys.
We actually
set you all up
with your own
personal pair of MUVEZ.
Ryan: So, please pull
the pull tab in front of you.
Lift it up.
Eric: Yeah, Robert,
we made yours red
to match
one of your racecars.
Lori, the closest thing
we had to white for the queen
was our stone gray.
Cuban: You gave me
Carolina blue?
No. [ Laughs ]
You gave me Carolina blue?
Look at the side of the box,
Mark, on the other side.
It's in the front.
We actually named it...
After you and your team.
Mavericks blue?
Um, Carolina blue.
Ryan: [ Laughing ]
You're right. You're right.
Daymond,
those are our most popular
in the streetwear industry,
the all blacks.
I mean,
if one of the Sharks
want to come up
and help demonstrate.
Just like you would
kick off your normal shoes,
like how you step on
the back of your shoes.
Zamora: Yeah, so, basically,
what you want to do
is when you come home
and you're entering your house,
you want to remove
the outer sole.
So you're gonna plant your toes
down firmly on the ground,
step on the back,
and then lift forward.
Eric: Like you would
with your normal shoes.
Then lift forward.
‐There you go.
‐There it is.
Zamora: Yeah, so,
the back is designed
for when you want to move
a little bit more,
so it's
an elastic heel counter.
‐That's cool.
‐What do you think, Daymond?
‐I think they're cool.
‐Thank you.
John:
The design is cool, too.
We focused very much
on the design itself.
What do you
sell them for?
$110,
and they include shipping.
And what's
your cost to land?
$26.
That's good.
And what have you sold?
So, we've done $73,000 in sales
since April,
with practically
zero marketing spent.
‐Online? All online?
‐Online.
So, basically, majority
of our sales are e‐commerce,
so it goes through
our social‐media channels.
What we're doing in
the second phase of the business
is allowing the customers to buy
the outer soles separately.
Cuban: Right.
So now you're building
your collection.
How much does it cost
you to make one, and what
would you sell it for?
Just the outsole is $8.
$8? Right. And you can sell it
for $19 or $29 or whatever?
‐Yeah. Exactly.
‐Right.
So that's where your
real money's gonna come from.
Ryan: Yeah.
But there could be an add‐on
during the checkout process.
This is cool as hell.
Zamora: It's been a really big
impulse purchase,
but the best part
about it is,
we have a less than 2%
return rate.
Tell me about your challenges
you had when creating this.
Where do we start?
Yeah.
Well, we traveled
to China twice.
Our first factory,
after financing samples
and mold costs
and material sourcing,
they were about three
to four months into it,
and they told us that
the project was impossible.
It couldn't be done.
It could not be done.
So we, honestly,
truth be told,
we purchased supplies
from an over‐the‐counter
hardware store,
brought them to our garage
in New Jersey...
Nice.
...where they casted my foot
as the mold.
And then that was our first
proof of concept with rubber.
Power of broke, baby.
That's it, yeah.
That's all it is.
It wasn't perfect,
but for us, it was beautiful,
and it was enough to present
to investors.
'Cause it showed
that it worked.
So, guys,
I'm not a slippers guy.
‐Okay.
I'm not a "shoes, bro"
household, right?
[ Laughter ]
How are you gonna get
to the point where you
have enough people
where you can sell enough
that it matters?
Well, we're hoping to utilize
a platform of athletes,
because they have
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions, of followers
on Instagram.
Why are athletes
attracted to this?
Zamora: At first,
it was a big focus
to position ourselves
as the postgame footwear.
But I think
that's a different market.
Isn't that like ‐‐
Well, it's athleisure.
A lot of people
actually have indoor slippers
and then outdoor slippers.
So they'll have
their pair of slippers
that they only wear
in their house.
I think that's
a New Jersey thing.
It's a very
cultural thing.
No, it's not. It's not. I know
a lot of people that do that.
People wear slippers
outside now.
Yeah.
So, what we're doing is,
we're pitching the comfort
and convenience,
but we're adding
functionality
and then, also, capitalizing
on the hygiene factor.
It's different.
There's no question
about it.
You walked in here
with something we
haven't seen before.
Absolutely.
And when it comes to shoes,
that's rare.
But to me,
it's not proven yet.
I admire what you're trying
to do, but it ‐‐
Mr. O'Leary,
just to speak to that.
To me, this is a tough,
tough, tough business.
Yeah.
I don't find your valuation
crazy.
I find the risk crazy.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Appreciate that. Thank you.
Guys, my challenge is not
the product or design.
I think we all loved it
up here.
I think
the branding part of it
is gonna be really,
really hard.
I wish you all the best,
'cause it's a fantastic product.
I just don't know how
you're gonna get it
to market like that
without burning
massive amounts of money.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Appreciate your feedback.
Cuban: Yeah, guys,
I'm kind of in the same boat.
It's hard, and you guys
already know that.
And I don't even think
it's about the amount of money.
It's just ‐‐
It's gonna be a slog.
I just don't have an angle
where I can just walk in
and say, "This is it."
And if I don't see
that angle
that I can just take ahold of
and run with it,
then it's just not a deal
for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
I think it's really
quite brilliant.
Ryan: Thank you.
You know, for me,
as an investment ‐‐
They're very cool.
Thank you.
As an investment for me,
I'm just not sure ‐‐
Zamora: So, the way we see
you helping us
is definitely with your
expertise in QVC
and getting us
in front of the eyes.
Listen,
there's so many people
that do not want shoes
in the house.
‐Oh, for sure.
‐Absolutely.
If you can get another Shark
here to go in with me,
I'll go in.
But I'm gonna leave that
to you now.
‐Oh, for sure.
‐That's fair.
Herjavec: Daymond,
you're the only one left.
♪♪
This is a tough one.
So, Daymond,
I know you have Bombas Socks,
so we know that is
a very good integration.
Yeah, I also own
the company Etonic, as well,
the footwear company.
Yes.
But this is a ‐‐
man, this is a tough one.
I love the design,
I love the product,
the ingenuity.
So I don't want to even
insult you with an offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Lori may be interested
in Ryan, Eric, and Kevin's
removable‐sole shoe company,
MUVEZ,
but wants to partner
with another Shark.
Herjavec: Daymond,
you're the only one left.
This is a ‐‐
man, this is a tough one.
I love the design.
I love the product,
the ingenuity.
So I don't want to even
insult you with an offer.
♪♪
Well, let's hear it.
Um...
Ryan: Would you be willing
to possibly go in with Lori?
Offering money
is never an insult, Daymond.
‐Never an insult.
‐We care more about ‐‐
Never. Never be insulted
by money.
Alright, so,
I'm just letting you know,
the reason why
I would give you this offer
is because purely I would be
taking you someplace
to license this.
You do not want to do
this business yourself.
‐Absolutely.
‐100%.
You really don't want
to do this.
Zamora: And that's
the way we see it.
For us,
we're looking for, you know,
the Shark to partner with
to get that exit strategy.
It would be $200,000
for 1/3 of the company.
‐Hello.
‐1/3 of the company.
‐Is Lori in on that deal?
‐Is Lori?
Absolutely not.
♪♪
‐Just 33%.
‐[ Laughs ]
Cuban:
You guys can counter.
Oh, yes, definitely.
Lori, do you have anything
to offer, as well?
I've not been in
the men's footwear space before.
I think it's more
I just would prefer
to have one of the Sharks
with me on this.
Daymond would have been
a great partner,
but he threw me
under the bus.
‐Yeah.
‐So, yeah.
I mean, my main goal
would be licensing.
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah. Same.
What do you think
of his offer?
I think it's a great offer.
Herjavec:
Are you gonna take it?
I would like to counter,
if you're okay
with $200,000 for 25%?
Eric: It's just so that
we can have 10% remaining
in case
we run into a roadblock
and we have to raise
additional capital.
And we're in New Jersey.
We're a stone's throw away
from your headquarters.
He's never been to New Jersey.
He's in Manhattan.
‐Really?
‐Well, we'll come to you.
But we know where
your office is.
Yeah.
We know
where your office is.
[ Laughter ]
‐"We've been stalking you."
‐I'm just saying.
Did they frisk
these people here?
And they know
where you live.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Let's do it.
‐Yes!
‐Whoo!
‐Let's go!
Let's go. Let's go.
Cuban: Congrats, guys.
That's awesome.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you so much.
Herjavec: Good job!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congrats.
O'Leary: He's the right Shark
for you guys.
Cuban: Good job, D. J.
That's a great deal.
[ Laughs ]
That was who we wanted,
too, man.
Eric:
Having Daymond on board,
we believe it can be
a global brand in a few years.
‐Whoo!
‐Whoo‐hoo‐hoo!
His licensing,
his manufacturing capabilities
will strengthen
and accelerate our growth,
and we couldn't be
happier.
Daymond is
our dream Shark.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 10,
Rohan Oza made a deal
with Allison
and Stephen Ellsworth
for their apple cider vinegar
drink, Mother Beverage.
$400,000 for 25%.
We'd love to do business
with you.
We'd love to do that.
‐Boom.
‐Alright!
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
On "Shark Tank,"
I was nine months pregnant.
I actually had the baby
about 12 days later.
What I don't think
people realize
is that
you can do it all.
You can live your dream,
have a company,
and have a family.
Stephen:
The night "Shark Tank" aired,
within a few hours,
we were sold out of products,
but we hit
a major roadblock.
We quickly learned
that we couldn't trademark
the word "Mother"
in Mother Beverage.
‐Yay!
‐Hey. What's up, guys?
Rohan advised us that
we needed to rename our company.
We had to say no
to all the retailers
that were approaching us.
Despite putting the business
on hold,
we still did $1 million
in business.
Look at the difference.
Like, what we've created
is unbelievable.
Mother Beverage
is now Poppi.
"Poppi" is a play
off of "soda pop."
Stephen:
It's an alternative to soda,
because it's low in sugar
and full of benefits.
Tomorrow's liquid
and tomorrow's brand.
Oza: I love how
this whole package turned out.
The design ‐‐ it's almost
like an artist designed it.
You want to grab it.
You see it on shelves,
you want to gravitate to it.
I love the brand so much that
I've doubled the investment.
We've got the formula.
Let's go launch Poppi.
♪♪
This is insane!
Allison: Rebranding gave
our business a new life.
Before "Shark Tank," we were
only in 200 retail locations.
Now we're launching in over
1,000 locations nationwide,
starting with Whole Foods,
Sprouts, and Lifetime Fitness.
Tastes amazing, and you feel
good about drinking it.
Oza: I haven't been
this excited about a beverage
since Bai nine years ago.
I want to have
the first billion‐dollar brand
on "Shark Tank."
I think Poppi
has that potential.
Great job, guys.
Cheers!
[ Cheering ]
Stephen: The whole
"Shark Tank" experience,
we honestly couldn't
have asked for more.
We got a deal with the Shark
that we wanted,
and we've created
a company and a brand
that we feel
truly amazing about.
All: Poppi!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to get a head start
in the college‐admissions
process.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks!
My name is Phil Black.
And if I look familiar,
it's because I stood right here
during Season 5,
when I pitched my FitDeck
Exercise Playing Cards.
‐Ohhhhh!
‐I remember you!
And although you passed on
investing in FitDeck,
you seemed open
to investing in me.
Remember this?
Phil, your résumé
is very impressive ‐‐
perhaps the best we've
ever seen on "Shark Tank."
I'm not kidding.
You are destined for much
greater things than this.
I'm giving you a free pass
to come back through the doors
with the next idea,
and I think everybody else here
would do the same.
I hope
I didn't make a mistake.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐He lied. [ Laughs ]
Well, Sharks, I am back.
And this time,
I've brought backup.
[ Laughter ]
These guys are the inspiration
behind my new business.
They also represent
my target market ‐‐
actual users.
And if you look closely,
you might even guess that...
yes, they're my sons.
And they're here
to help me secure a deal
for my new business,
called PrepWell Academy.
PrepWell Academy is an online,
video‐based mentoring program
that helps teenagers,
like these guys,
and their parents,
like me, navigate
the confusing and stressful
college‐admissions process.
And, boy,
could we use the help.
Guidance counselors
are overwhelmed,
schools don't have
the curriculum,
parents don't have the time,
and students
aren't getting the advice
when they need it most.
And that's where
PrepWell Academy comes in.
Every week, PrepWellers get
a video from me on their phone,
giving them exact advice,
timely advice
to help them know exactly
what to do and when to do it,
starting in ninth grade.
Sharks, this advice that I'm
giving ‐‐ it's not guesswork.
As you may recall, I have
cracked the code in getting into
some of the world's
most competitive programs.
It's my superpower!
And I share that superpower
with my students every week.
Today, my job is to ask you
to share your superpowers
with me
by investing
in PrepWell Academy.
And for that,
I'm seeking $100,000
for 20% of the business.
Now, boys, head over,
assume your positions.
[ Laughter ]
And, Sharks,
I would like my sons to help me
demonstrate exactly
how this program works.
Kiefer, for instance,
as a freshman,
every week,
he's gonna take out his phone,
and he's gonna get a lesson
and learn things
like study habits ‐‐
in this case,
how to take notes,
when to take notes,
and how to stay organized.
Then he'll move into
extracurricular activities ‐‐
how to think about
afterschool clubs.
What about volunteer work?
What about sports?
Now, Col and Croix, on
the other hand, as sophomores,
they're gonna learn
a different set of lessons ‐‐
things like how to avoid
the sophomore slump,
why colleges love leaders,
when to take the S. A. T.
or the A. C. T.
And these lessons
will continue week after week
through junior year
and senior year.
Now, Dexter ‐‐
he's got a couple years to go
before he becomes
a PrepWeller,
and I don't think it's gonna
take much to convince him
to follow
in his brothers' footsteps.
But my job today
is to convince you
to invest in me
and PrepWell Academy.
So, who's got questions?
John: Why were we so ‐‐
We see a lot of people,
of course.
I do remember that you had
an impressive background.
But can you run us through
that again?
I was a recruited athlete
coming out of high school.
I played basketball
for Yale University.
I was an investment banker
at Goldman Sachs.
That's what I remember.
Oh, that's right.
I was a Navy S. E. A. L. officer
and Navy S. E. A. L. instructor.
Yes.
Great. That's right.
Thank you for serving.
Greiner: Wow.
I have an MBA
from Harvard Business School.
And you have
one good‐looking family.
[ Laughs ] Thank you.
He had all that,
and then you had
a deck of cards, right?
Yeah.
Now, let's just ask,
how did that go?
I'm glad you asked,
Daymond.
I kept going, I sold more,
and we actually became a pretty
attractive acquisition target,
and I sold the business
to a company on the East Coast
who had a fitness brand
that they were building,
and FitDeck
was the perfect match.
Herjavec: Phil,
how do you make a living?
What do you do for a living,
if you don't mind me asking?
Yeah, I'm a firefighter.
‐Oh, you are?
‐You are?
I became a firefighter
after 9/11.
I've been so for 14 years.
‐Good for you.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh, my gosh!
He's, like, the best.
Black: I never even got to it
last time.
Phil, how do you make money
with this?
It's a subscription service,
Kevin.
Every month,
they get these videos
that help them
along the path.
Do you have any data that says
the attrition rates on this?
Subscribers?
You sign people up at what
customer acquisition costs?
Well, first, tell us how
many subscribers you have...
How long do they stay?
...and how much they pay.
220 subscribers.
So,
what do you charge?
It's $15 a month
for a subscription.
$15 a month.
And how long
have you been selling it?
A little over two years.
Oh!
Why do you bring us
the stuff that doesn't work?!
Phil, Phil, Phil.
I'm gonna give you
another pass to come back.
Black: It's working, Mark.
220 subscribers?!
Phil,
what are your sales?
$150,000.
Your sales
are $150,000?
Over two years?
Over two years, yes.
How do you get there
with 220 subscribers?
Well, there's a combination ‐‐
there's subscriber revenue,
there's my private
client revenue,
and then we have
a journal that we sell.
I'd like to know
how you came up with this idea.
Sure.
I came up with the idea
after I sold
the FitDeck business.
I had a little time
on my hands,
and I would see consistently
parents bickering
about this
college‐admissions stuff.
"How did Sally not get into
a school with a 4.9 GPA?"
"What should Billy do
for extracurriculars?"
And I got pulled into
one of these conversations,
and I said, "Phil, you got
into Harvard Business School.
You got into Yale.
What does it take to have kids
who are competitive
for the college‐admissions
process?"
So I started taking notes,
writing best practices,
writing lessons learned,
tips, strategies,
mind‐set
from the Navy S. E. A. L. s,
professionalism
from Goldman Sachs,
and the list got long.
Then I went back to school
to get credentialed
in college‐admissions
counseling,
and I put
these two things together,
and I started coaching
and mentoring kids.
I have to tell you,
sitting here, like,
I think it all seems
very, very smart.
I think that there's
just one problem.
It's hard to get people
to buy into something
that's that long,
that many months,
at that price.
I feel like if it was more
of, like, a crash course
or a course they bought once,
then they could buy in.
It's easier.
You know, you get more,
cheaper price point.
But to me, I don't relate to it
in this model.
I wish you the best of luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Here's my view ‐‐
I remember you last time.
It was unbelievably
impressive.
You have a passion,
and it keeps you going ‐‐
keeps you going
maybe past a point
where you shouldn't.
Two years
with 220 users ‐‐
it's ‐‐ it's not great.
I admire the mission,
and I applaud you for all
the other things you're doing,
but I'm out.
I don't see this business.
♪♪
A lot of people
don't want to adapt.
They don't want
to change,
even when they know
what's in their best interests.
You're trying to educate
people who may not...
What?!
...feel they need
education.
I'm out.
You took all the right steps,
but the product itself
is gonna be really tough
to scale, right?
Because it has to be
demonstrated
and it has to be seen
and it has to be experienced.
Then it has to be managed
after the fact
by having
the parents involved.
That's so much work
for a $15 subscription.
That's why
you have such great challenges.
And while 220
is not horrible...
Mm‐hmm.
...it's certainly not,
you know,
knocking any walls down.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
Phil,
220 is horrible.
And I just want to say,
as I said last time,
you're a really,
really great guy
with a really, really bad idea
this time.
This is horrible.
You're in
the top one percentile
of people that have
come on "Shark Tank."
Nobody gets invited back.
But because of the service
you've given your country
and your fantastic family
and what a great guy you are,
I'm inviting you back
again.
[ Laughs ]
But next time,
it's three strikes
and you're out.
Come back
with something better.
This sucks.
I'm out.
Phil, please, we all love you,
so come back.
And the next business
should be
"How to get on 'Shark Tank'
three times."
[ Laughter ]
‐I will be back if need be.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Beautiful family.
‐I appreciate all the advice.
‐I hope you come back.
‐Good luck, Phil.
‐Third time's the charm.
‐Nice to meet you guys.
Congrats. Good job.
‐Take care.
♪♪
Black: Hey, listen,
I'm a former Navy S. E. A. L.,
and I'm never gonna give up.
I can see myself
pushing this thing
for the next couple years
and seeing it through, like
I did with FitDeck last time,
and coming back.
I'm a serial entrepreneur.
This is the best place to be
in America for entrepreneurship,
and I'll take them up on it
again.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
designed to make a dreadful
household chore easier.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Lola, and I'm from
Los Angeles, California.
I'm here asking for $150,000
for 10% of my business, Beddley.
Sharks, let's face it ‐‐
the duvet cover struggle
is real.
It's definitely one of the most
frustrating tasks ever.
First, you may have to crawl
your way into your cover.
[ Laughter ]
After that, trying to line up
all four corners
while somehow
getting out of this maze
is beyond me.
Now you're lost, confused,
disoriented
and almost cannot breathe.
[ Laughter ]
And when you finally
make it out alive,
you're left jumping up and down
on your bed
in hopes that your comforter
will magically line up.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
All of the sweat and hassle!
Making your bed does not
have to be challenging,
complicated, or stressful.
There's got to be a better way.
That's why I created
the easiest, fastest,
and most user‐friendly
duvet cover ever known.
Introducing the Beddley.
Our signature
innovative duvet cover
has a three‐sided opening
that makes inserting
or removing your duvet
a breeze like never before.
Simply unzip the three sides,
place your duvet on top,
straighten things out.
The Beddley duvet cover
is just very easy to use.
Even a child can handle it.
And, Sharks,
no need for crawling inside.
So, now she's gonna zip
the duvet cover up
using our signature
nylon zipper.
Zip, zip, zip.
So, no more stuffing, shoving,
or, you know, duvet gymnastics.
Ta‐da! Good job.
With Beddley, it's so easy.
Yay!
Think about
how much time you saved
and what you can do
with that precious time.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to zip up this deal with me
and bring Beddley
to beds everywhere?
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
I have samples for you.
♪♪
Robert.
Thank you very much,
Lola.
You're welcome.
Lori.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful
is getting white.
He is pure
as the driven snow.
He is pure, yeah.
And Daymond.
John: Thank you.
Thank you.
And Mark.
Thank you, Lola.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
♪♪
So, you Sharks may not know
the difference
between a blanket
and a duvet.
Let me explain
the difference.
[ Laughs ]
‐Well, Mark doesn't.
‐I certainly do not.
Because he probably
doesn't make his bed.
The duvet was
first made popular
in the French courts
in Versailles.
Thank you so much.
It is a down‐filled,
large pillow.
And so the duvet cover
allowed them
to not have to wash the down
every time.
They had to wash
just the cover.
And so duvets
became immensely popular
with royalty
all around the world.
What years were those?
These are
back in the 1400s.
How old were you then?
Back when you were
in high school?
[ Laughter ]
I am a duvet expert.
Lola, it looked complicated,
even when she did it.
‐No.
‐No?
‐No, that was easy.
Greiner:
That was very easy.
Lola: Lori gets it.
And it's not complicated at all.
How would I know that
from looking at the packaging?
Yeah, that's gonna be
my question.
Yeah.
Like,
if I'm in the store ‐‐
Okay.
Or do you only sell
this online today?
Oh, right now
just online.
So, you have a video
demonstrating what we just saw?
On the website.
Absolutely.
John:
Yeah. On the website?
Because otherwise,
why would I know the
difference between this ‐‐
Yeah, because
it's a demonstrable ‐‐
Yeah, like, I wouldn't
have known to do that.
So, when you pick that up
on the retail shelf,
hopefully, you look
at that label,
and it tells you.
It has
a three‐sided opening.
It's hard to know that, though,
Lola, from looking at it.
Because it's very small
in the representation.
I wouldn't know that.
Okay.
And you don't have anything
there that says that.
Okay.
Well, Lola,
tell us about you, okay?
So,
what's your background?
So, equipped with a degree
in chemistry and physics,
I'm originally from Nigeria,
so I immigrated to the U. S.
I ended up getting a job
in investment banking
on the technology side.
And then,
while working full time,
I went to Columbia
and got my MBA.
I've always had this
entrepreneurial yearning,
so I'm brainstorming,
what ideas can I ‐‐
you know, what can I ‐‐
So, then, I'm like,
"Every time I have to wash
my duvet cover,
for a king‐size bed,
it's a pain."
And I'm not a lazy person,
but that was the one thing
I did not like doing.
I'm like, "No.
This has got to stop.
There's got to be a solution
to this."
So I looked.
I didn't find it.
So I decided
I'm gonna make one.
Everybody
has this problem...
Yeah. Yeah.
...if they've ever changed
their duvet cover.
Exactly.
So, what does it cost you
to make it,
and the units that you sold,
what did you sell them at?
Right now
it's made in the U. S.
Okay.
So our costs are very high,
and I know I can
get that down drastically.
Okay.
What are the costs?
So, right now
it's $57.50.
To make?
Yes.
And I know
I can get this down.
And you sell it for what?
$130, $140 average.
Well,
what are your sales?
Okay, so, I'm gonna
preface that with
do not judge me
by my sales.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
We promise you we will not
judge you by your sales.
I am going to judge you
by your sales.
$150,000 for 10% imputes
a $1.5 million valuation.
It does.
'Cause you're an investment
banker. You know that.
I know. I know that.
Okay, so ‐‐
But you know what?
I wasn't gonna let
sales that are not gonna be
pleasing to you...
Herjavec: They're not.
...stop me...
Uh‐oh. Uh‐oh.
...from getting here.
Yeah,
don't worry about it.
I'll just tell you
the sales.
So, our revenue from 2018,
because that was when
we really started to sell.
Before that, it was just
a few here and there.
Just for last year,
what were the sales?
$28,000.
♪♪
Uh‐oh.
That's amazing!
We're not impressed.
Okay, Lola,
we don't live in the past.
Thank you.
We do not live
in the past.
‐Okay, and so this year ‐‐
‐So, 2019, year‐to‐date?
Yeah.
2019 year‐to‐date
is about $12,000.
‐Oh!
‐Yeah!
‐Whoo!
‐Now we're judging you.
‐Listen to Lola.
This is important.
Don't get stuck on the numbers.
Listen to me.
Lola, your sales ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
You aren't gonna like it.
Your sales suck!
It's okay.
I've been bootstrapping.
On this, I've spent like
$91,000 ‐‐ all my own money.
And because my budget
was so limited,
it wasn't gonna stop me,
so I hustled.
You didn't hustle enough.
♪♪
Why do you think
you didn't sell more?
I haven't been doing
a lot of marketing.
Tell you what I've done.
Right now we have this
in a Macy's pop‐up shop,
and I've been talking
to QVC...
You're in Macy's?
...and they like it enough
to put it on there.
Yeah.
With this packaging?
Pop‐up shop, yeah,
at two locations.
♪♪
Lola,
this is a quality product,
but for me, respectfully,
it's not a product for me,
but I wish you the best.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
Lola, you deserve
a ton of credit, right?
Thank you.
What you've accomplished
is amazing.
Your relentlessness
Thank you.
Your sales ‐‐
not so much.
Yeah, but ‐‐
Right?
But it's telling you
something.
Honestly,
I'm not a marketing expert,
but I said,
"I'm not gonna stop, you know?"
You've got $91,000 of your own
money that you've spent.
You don't have enough money
for marketing.
You know, I don't want
to keep saying this,
but it is what it is.
I haven't been able
to give this product
the brand awareness
that it deserves.
Most of our customers,
they find us on Google...
Right, but, you know...
...and they don't even
search for long.
...marketing is
really a black hole.
If you don't
figure it out now...
Mm‐hmm.
...how are you gonna
figure it out with the money?
What do you expect
to come out of this?
But I've learned a lot.
I've seen a lot.
And then I can also ‐‐
I need help.
I can get help.
I think it's a genius idea.
You know what?
You're doing something
that's very important.
You're saving people time,
right?
And that's a lot of times
why people purchase something.
I just don't think
you've figured it out yet,
so I'm out.
Oh. Okay. Thank you.
Herjavec:
Lola, I, um...
There's a great saying ‐‐
I forget where I saw it ‐‐
"Every time you see somebody
with a small business..."
Yeah.
"...somebody made
a courageous decision."
Yes.
So I admire
your courage.
Thank you.
You are in love
with the romantic idea
of starting a business.
But my money's
got to go somewhere
in order to get back
an investment.
Okay.
And today,
you didn't do a good job
of presenting that.
Oh, wow.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
Lola, you're going through
the same thing
a lot of entrepreneurs
go through...
Okay.
...where they have
a great product
and they say to themselves,
"Well, I can't really sell
a lot of them.
It must mean I don't have
enough money for marketing.
And if I only had more money
for marketing,
I could build a brand.
And if I build a brand,
then everybody will
come rushing to me and buy it."
Except that never works.
Marketing dollars
never build brands.
Product satisfaction
and execution build brands.
I don't think
you've got it figured ‐‐
But I've been
working hard on this.
Who doesn't?
I got it into Macy's!
Everybody works hard.
Greiner: Everybody does.
I got it into Macy's.
Who doesn't?
I got QVC interested.
Ha.
Lola, self‐awareness is key
for every entrepreneur.
Absolutely.
We all lie to ourselves ‐‐
some more than others.
You're in the "more" category
right now.
You've got to get
to the "less" category.
[ Scoffs ]
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Kevin?
Kevin didn't speak.
And then there's Kevin.
That's shocking, too.
No.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Never. No.
[ Laughs ]
I'm out.
♪♪
‐Okay.
‐Good luck, Lola.
‐Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
♪♪
[ Laughing ] "No."
Lola: I think the Sharks were
hung up on my sales numbers,
but I know that all I need
is just one breakthrough
and I can push this
into the millions.
This woman has an MBA.
She got an MBA.
Are you saying that
in a good way or a bad way?
I'm saying I'm not a fan
of MBAs anymore.
I got to tell you guys
something.
We've been together
10 years...
Herjavec: 11.
...and it's
the first time ever
in "Shark Tank" history
I was speechless.
[ Chuckles ]
All I could think of
was "No."
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Hello, "Shark Tank" fans.
We appreciate you, and we'd like
to take a moment to warn you
about a concerning problem ‐‐
scam ads.
There are businesses
that are advertising
online and on social media
claiming to be
"Shark Tank" companies,
but they've never appeared
on the show.
Many of these businesses
use the names
and images of us Sharks
in attempt to sell you
their product.
Corcoran: They might even show
a photoshopped picture
of their product in the Tank.
Before you buy,
please go to ABC's
official "Shark Tank" website
to see a full list
of all businesses
that have been on our show.
Be careful out there,
and thank you for watching
"Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a modern version of a classic.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name's Jason Richardson,
and I'm from
Los Angeles, California.
Today, I'm looking for $300,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company, Bad Birdie.
Now, before we talk about
the birdie,
unfortunately,
we have to talk about the bad.
You walk into any golf store,
pro shop,
search any online retailer,
and you're gonna see
these basic options
for golf polos ‐‐
solid colors
or, if you're feeling
a little bit more edgy,
you can go
with the stripes.
Guys, get out of here.
O'Leary: Wow. Bye.
‐Aww.
As you can see,
most options are safe,
they're unoriginal,
and they're based on
the outdated, overly proper,
boring golf culture
of the past.
So meet Bad Birdie.
Bad Birdie makes
performance golf polos
with the freshest,
the most fun styles
that make you stand out
on the course.
They're moisture‐wicking,
anti‐odor, antimicrobial,
and they offer
sun protection.
They fit amazing,
and they just look sick,
baby!
[ Laughs ]
People are loving it,
and we cannot keep up
with the demand.
So, Sharks,
who's looking to pour
a little bit of fuel
on this fire
and blow this thing up?
Let's go, baby!
Sharks, there's some polos
for each of you guys.
Herjavec: Alright.
Oh, I love this.
Love this pattern.
Richardson: That's one of
our best sellers.
John: Jason,
I got a question for you.
Yeah.
Why would anybody
play golf?
‐Aw, Daymond!
‐Oh, Daymond!
I mean, like,
I hate golf!
I've heard that
from so many people.
Golf has a history
of being boring.
It's dull.
It's overly proper.
But golf is becoming
more popular
for the younger generation.
But you don't need to golf
to wear this.
No, you don't.
But that's my point, right,
'cause this is ‐‐
They are performance,
so these are made performance
for on the course.
They have all the technical
features of any other golf polo.
But they're
cool‐looking shirts.
‐Thanks. Yeah.
‐I love golf. It's wonderful.
I'm good for
the first two hours.
After that, I'm like,
"I can't believe I'm
out here for five hours."
Yeah.
There is a lot of stuff
like this in the market.
There's several companies
in golf
that have targeted
the older golfer,
those that are, say,
40 and up.
Tell us what your plan is
to gain market share.
What's the plan?
To give you guys
some context,
I started this company
2 1/2 years ago.
I walked into a golf store,
and I was trying to find
something cool,
and I was like, "There's
got to be someone out there
that wants to buy
a shirt like this."
I have no background
in apparel,
no idea
how to make a golf polo,
so I just started Googling,
"How do I make a golf polo?"
[ Laughter ]
So, I just started making
as many calls as I can,
hustling, figuring it out.
Spent 20,000
of my own dollars.
In the first year,
I did $72,000.
‐Wow!
‐Good for you.
The second year,
I sold $412,000.
$412,000 in sales?
$412,000.
This year, to date,
I'm at $760,000.
I should close the year
at $1.2 million.
Wow!
And we'll close
at $1.2 million.
Hustler, hustler.
I like it.
So, my sales go like this.
You're all online?
It's all online
until this last year.
But just so you have
context of sales,
when I release these polos,
I have loyal customers that buy
within the first hour
they come out.
And my problem has been
I continually sell out,
and I'm reinvesting cash flow
into it
to be able to buy inventory,
and I keep hitting
that max level.
So they wait for
your drop date, right?
Yeah, so, it depends
on the shirts.
Generally, I do drops
every two months.
If it's a superhot seller ‐‐
like, example, this one
right here is called Wildlife.
That was just launched
a month ago,
and it sold so well
within the first hour
that it's gonna move into
our best sellers category.
That's my favorite.
How many new designs a year
are you gonna drop?
Per season,
I do about 30 designs.
And then, on top of that,
I do limited‐edition runs.
Who does the design?
I started doing them all myself
with graphic designers.
Now I've basically
built a team
of probably 10 or so designers
that I work with.
What does it cost
to manufacture,
and what do you
sell it for?
So, I sell these polos
for $72.
I started making them
for $40.
Now I make them for $25,
and my next run
coming from overseas
is coming in for $17.
Wow.
And within the next six months,
I should be able
to get that down
to about $12.
Where do you make them now?
Here?
So, right now I've made them
all in L. A.
Last year,
I started selling wholesale.
So far this year, we've done
about $150,000 of wholesale.
By the end of this month,
I'll have $300,000
committed for next year.
Why do you feel that you need
to expand in retail
if you're doing so well
online?
Yeah,
I think I want to do that
because it's an opportunity
and it helps grow the brand.
And each shirt is gonna have
a run of how many?
For next year, I'll probably be
doing 1,000 to 2,000 per shirt.
Okay,
the reason I ask that,
as opposed to going
to retail, right...
Yeah.
...every kid right now,
every Millennial, Gen Z, right,
you're trained by shoes,
right,
that the drop date
is the date.
Mm‐hmm.
Jordan XXXIV ‐‐
when's it gonna hit, right?
Everybody's
waiting in line.
When you told me
you were doing that,
I'm like,
"That's brilliant."
Yeah.
Because that's
what connects you...
Yeah.
...to golfers
that are 30 and under.
Now, the minute you've got
those same lines
in a retail store...
Yeah.
...there's nobody
waiting in line.
They're not gonna
sell out.
Do you see
the difference there?
I 100% see the difference.
What you've got right now is
this incredible momentum online
at full‐margin
cash flow...
You're killing it.
...on these drops.
Thank you. Yeah.
And we see ‐‐
you've got to believe us ‐‐
we see
so many apparel deals...
Totally.
...where the guys
get buried!
Been there, done that.
It sucks.
This conversation has gone
a lot about retail.
I'm only projecting
to keep retail
at like 25% or less
of my business.
That's not the point.
It's not the percentage, right?
It's the relationship
with the buyer.
If you already paid $72,
you can pay $99, right?
Yeah.
If you can pay $99,
you can pay $129.
When those drops
are limited...
Yeah.
So, I just want to jump in here
for a minute.
Yeah.
Your shirts ‐‐
you walked in here,
and you said the reason
why you did all of this ‐‐
this is
your niche market ‐‐
is because everything's boring
out there, right?
Yeah. Totally.
So, if that's true,
if your competition
is boring,
anywhere you then put
your shirts
amidst the sea
of "dull"...
Yeah.
...you're gonna pop
and stand out.
100%.
That's a really good point.
And people are gonna
gravitate to it.
Yeah.
So you can do it all,
so to speak.
Yep.
Anyway, I think that
some of my fellow Sharks
are more interested
in investing in a golf shirt
than I am.
I just don't find that it's
the right investment for me,
so I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
I appreciate that.
I was looking at this,
saying,
there is no way in hell
I'd put $300,000 into apparel,
where there is
so much competition.
But sales don't lie.
Here's my offer ‐‐
I'll give you $300,000.
I forbid you
to go to retail.
I don't care
what Lori says.
$300,000 for 30%.
But zero retail.
Zero retail
to take that offer?
Do you know why?
You have to beg to get
that shirt on the drop date ‐‐
beg like a dog for it.
Herjavec: Jason,
I don't see it like that.
Thanks for the offer.
I think when you're hot,
you got to stay hot.
I don't know how this all became
completely about retail.
No, no.
To me, it's like you said.
I'm riding the wave.
And you know what?
When the wave crests,
you can always pull back.
We have a great investment in
a company called Butter Cloth.
We're all online,
about $3.5 million.
But I like this
because it's all about
targeting your customer.
That's great.
I'll give you the $300,000
for 25%.
And you're a smart guy.
I won't forbid you
to sell more anywhere.
You'll figure it out, and I
think we can really help you.
Okay.
Cuban: As much as
I like the concept,
retail always scares me.
Totally.
I will tell you,
jack up your prices, bro.
If you're selling out...
Sell it more. Yeah.
...you're selling
too cheap.
Yeah.
I'm excited for you.
It's just not
a fit for me right now.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Appreciate it, Mark.
Let me tell you something ‐‐
retail is about real estate.
They start charging you
for hanging fees.
Yep.
You have to sell it
at half the price
that you sold online,
right?
They pay you
in 30, 60, maybe 90 days.
They return goods
they don't like.
It is horrible.
I don't want to put
that pressure on you. I'm out.
O'Leary:
So, you have two offers, Jason.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Jason is seeking $300,000
for a 10% stake
in his modern golf shirt
business, Bad Birdie.
Kevin has offered
$300,000 for 30%,
and Robert has offered
$300,000 for 25%.
O'Leary:
So, you have two offers.
I want you to know the great
story of Greek mythology,
the siren on the rocks.
[ Laughs ]
You know who that was?
It was a retailer.
It was retail.
I know, yeah.
I bring a discipline
to the business
because I have experience.
My family business years ago,
Kiddie Togs,
was children's clothing.
Retail was very damaging
to us.
Yes. Yes.
Kevin 100 years ago
was in clothing.
Kiddie Togs?
I'm in clothing now
for people your age.
My final point is,
who do you want
wearing your shirt ‐‐
Kevin or me?
So, Robert,
let me ask you this ‐‐
Yeah?
Are you willing to go down
to 20% on this?
No. No.
We know what this takes.
It's a partnership, and we
got to have at least 25%.
25%'s a little bit more than ‐‐
you know,
that's doubling the equity
I was asking you for.
It's the Shark Tank.
What do you expect?
I know it's "Shark Tank," and
I'm here to make a deal, so ‐‐
Stick to your guns.
Give me one second here.
I got a little something.
Okay.
♪♪
Robert, you said
you're a golfer.
I am a golfer.
This is what
we're gonna do.
Either way,
I want to accept your offer.
If you make a putt,
I'll give you 25%.
But if you miss the putt,
it's 20%.
Whoo!
Ooh.
I'll do it.
[ Laughs ]
Alright.
Let's shake on the deal
first.
Yeah! [ Laughs ]
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Let me line it up for you.
One or one out of three?
One.
I'm loving this!
Here we go.
I used to be a caddie.
You want some help?
Come on, man! I used to be
a 6 handicap.
Either way,
it's a win‐win situation.
Don't miss the putt.
Shut up!
Robert,
don't overthink the putt.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Don't overthink the putt.
Focus, Robert.
Miss! Mah!
Cuban: Be the ball.
Be the ball.
Mah!
♪♪
[ Gasps ]
Ohhhhhhh!     Ohhhhhhh!
Ohhhhhhh!              Ohhhhhhh!
‐You're a loser!
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Alright, man.
Appreciate it.
That was fantastic.
Let me just
show you something.
Let's see what you got.
Let me show you
why you wish it wasn't me...
Damn it!
...because
I'm gonna sink that.
Kevin, I bet
you won't sink that.
Watch this, you bozo.
I will bet you $5,000
to your favorite charity
or you give $5,000
to mine.
You know what?
No, no, no, no.
Greiner: Do it!
I'm gonna take another
5% from you.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see you do it,
Mr. O'Leary.
Richardson:
Decent form.
Ohhhhh!     Ohhhhh!
Ohhhhh!                  Ohhhhh!
You suck!
Two losers!
[ Laughs ]
Congrats, guys.
Good luck.
Let's go, baby!
Whoo! Whoo!
Robert's gonna bring
a lot to the company.
Just the fact that
he believed in me enough
to risk 5% is amazing.
He understands the whole
conversation about retail.
He's grown other brands
before. It's just gonna
be an epic journey.
♪♪
‐Hey, we're ‐‐
‐I know. And...
And the one that doesn't play
hits it.
‐What?!
‐Oh, you got it?
Charge $10,000 for it.
Did you get it in?
You did?
Seriously?
♪♪